my name is Nick Brown and I'm an
Egyptologist here in Los Angeles and I
study ancient Egypt so today I'm
watching different video clips from
Hollywood movies to check how accurate
or inaccurate they are in depicting
ancient Egypt I'm expecting that a lot
of the clips that I'm gonna watch today
are gonna be full of a lot of errors and
a lot of things that actually aren't
true for ancient Egypt so in the case of
a monument like the Pyramids at Giza
we have evidence lets us know that it
was actually ancient Egyptians
themselves who were building these
monuments with almost like a conscripted
workforce or perhaps even as like a form
of tax or tribute of some kind to the
living king they don't say anything
though the ancient Egyptians did have
different forms of Oracle's they
actually never as far as we know would
cut open animals and look at the
entrails and try to figure out the
future based off these animal entrails
and stuff so this already is has been a
blatant issue with with this clip one of
the other problems with this clip is
blending or merging of both like the
palace area and the settlement like
right alongside the pyramids of Memphis
these actually would have been separated
in reality most of the palaces and the
settlement and the city itself would
have probably been on the east bank of
the Nile and separated from the many
pyramids most of which aren't even real
or in existence in this clip like me
father don't stay out of the Sun I won't
fight I love you brother with all my
heart so one of the very few things
that's actually accurate about this clip
in ancient Egyptian mythology it does
say that Seth the god of chaos did
murder his brother Osiris so I will let
that be true
most of the weapons that these gods are
using to fight each other we don't
actually really have anything that looks
like that from ancient Egypt so this
type of spear that Seth is using is
based off an object from Egypt but it
was not used as a weapon the types of
shields that they're using again the the
armor that they're wearing made of solid
gold and things like this it seems to be
a very exaggerated reality of the truth
in this story that we have preserved the
contending zuv Horus and Seth there is a
part where Seth takes one of the eyes of
Horus causing him to lose his sight
Horus with the help of his mother Isis
and the god Thoth actually gets his
sight restored with new eye from Thoth
called the Eye of Horus or the Waja tie
this is the the Ten Commandments done by
Cecil B DeMille people slaves are mine
lives are mine all that they own is mine
the clip is pretty faithful to the
biblical story most of what the story
that the Bible talks about says we don't
actually have evidence for in ancient
Egypt's one of the issues again with
movies about ancient Egypt is that they
did popularize a lot of misconceptions
about ancient Egypt such as the pyramids
were built by enslaved peoples it's also
really troubling that all the characters
in these movies are like completely
white and like not actually like North
African or Middle Eastern or
what-have-you a classic from my
childhood these city of the living okay
one of the problems already with this
one is Thebes is modern-day Luxor which
is in the south of Egypt and all of our
pyramids from ancient Egypt are up in
the north near Cairo so I'm not sure
what the pyramids are doing there in
Thebes but there we go
birthplace of an ox with a woman
Pharaoh's mistress I should mention that
the two characters so far in hotel and
Uncas and a moon those are two real
people that we have from ancient Egypt
however in hotep was the architect of
the Step Pyramid at Saqqara he was alive
during dynasty 3 which is around 2600 BC
something like this what he's doing in
the New Kingdom around 1300 BC I'm not
entirely sure
and then Uncas and a moon was
the wife of King Tutankhamen she was not
a mistress either so again some creative
license there also the ancient Egyptians
had a lot of gold but I am not entirely
sure what's going on with the entire
bodies being painted in this gold paint
the ancient Egyptian language we are
able to read and write hieroglyphs but
we consider it a dead language because
we don't know for certain how it was
spoken or vocalized the actors and the
script is using real words how they were
actually pronounced is open for debate
and interpretation this clip from
Cleopatra is actually probably the most
historically accurate the one whose
total assets up to a few moments ago was
a devoted slave and a rolled-up carpet
Caesar mentions that Cleopatra came to
visit him rolled up in a carpet and from
our historical texts seem to think that
that's how she was able to meet Caesar
the first time I should have to insist
that you mind what you say I am Isis I
am worshipped by millions who believe it
Cleopatra
saw herself as a form of the goddess
Isis and this we also know to be true
from the Egyptian sources themselves
you've seen my brother and listen to him
and that treaty even to whom he belongs
as far as we know it is true that when
Cleopatra ascended the throne there was
a civil war going on in Egypt between
her and her younger brother Ptolemy xiii
it got to the point where it was so bad
that Cleopatra actually needed the help
of the ancient Romans in order to defeat
her brother to take the throne for
herself
Hollywood is basing their stories and
the way they're making these movies on
some facts and some truth that we have
from ancient Egypt so overall I think
for popular entertainment there they're
fun they're great for people to see and
stuff but in terms of actually learning
about ancient Egypt I would err on the
side of caution when watching Clips like
this
[Music]